Lucan 8 here at the outdoor boys youtube
channel and we're gonna find out whether
you can make one of these super polished
aluminum foil balls by simply sticking
tin foil in a microwave
[Music]
last week we had a great time making
some videos where we took balls of
aluminum foil and compressed them and
polished them till they absolutely
shined kind of pointless but it's
actually kind of fun we have a great
time doing that with me and the boys and
we got a lot of awesome comments from
people and one of those common comments
we got was people encouraging me to put
it in microwave they said that if you
take a ball of aluminum foil and
microwave it for three to five minutes
it'll turn into this and you don't need
to spend all that time hammering and
polishing and all that stuff and I did a
little searching around it turns out
people are saying this because there's a
video out there where some guy says you
can do that just that and he puts a ball
of aluminum foil in hits it for a few
minutes and out pops a perfectly
polished sphere of aluminum so we're
gonna find out what happens when you put
a ball of aluminum foil in the microwave
and whether or not you can polish
aluminum by heating it up hey Becca can
I put an aluminum ball in the microwave
no can i light a fire no can i melt
aluminum foil in the microwave yeah how
about now for those of you who do not
know putting aluminum foil and a
microwave can be exciting so let me just
put this little tiny bit in there just
to give you a flavor for what to expect
[Music]
let's check it out
[Music]
you know it's cool to the touch it's not
even warm so this right here is an
entire roll of aluminum foil that's been
compressed into a ball we're gonna put
it in here and see what happens now some
people have left comments that if we put
it in the microwave for three to five
minutes it'll make it really perfectly
smooth and make it all glossy we're
gonna find out what happens we're gonna
put it in for about five minutes and
just find out
[Music]
well this is disappointing it's not
popping or exploding or lighting on fire
or anything it's actually more dramatic
with just a little tiny piece of
aluminum than with the whole big ball
but who knows it still might polish it
might melt it down and make it easier to
to polish it we'll find out I'm gonna
let it go the full five minutes all
right check this out it's just a little
bit warm that's it
didn't do anything that was epically
disappointing well guys you came here to
see sparks and fireworks and crazy
microwave stuff so we got to put more
tin foil in the microwave don't we yeah
let's do this thing yeah we're going to
make something happen here
all right I did burn a little bit back
there that melted the plastic and burned
a little hole back there
Oh a little bit here too huh well
apparently loose aluminum foil duh
makes it up and go crazy but compacted
compressed lumen in foil does not so I'm
gonna try something crazy just put a
loose ball of aluminum foil in there and
see what happens
see what we got barely even warm little
hole right there little little hole
right there little hole right there but
ya didn't really do much of anything
just put a few holes in it made it
slightly warm made some sparks
disappointing bird in the microwave a
burn in the microwave that was fun but I
think it's pretty clear you cannot
create a super polished ball of aluminum
simply by sticking some tin foil in the
microwave I think somebody was pulling a
little prank on the internet with that
video additionally I got a load of
comments from my my mates across the
pond informing me that I was spelling
alluminium incorrectly there are two
correct spellings for aluminum or
aluminium depending on what type of
English you like to speak British
English it's aluminium with an extra I
and here in the great US of A in America
we say aluminium thanks for watching we
hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video